hello everyone and welcome to a really
wild game from the second day of the ftx
road to miami preliminaries it is wei yi
versus joe engine uh you guys know both
of them but for those of you who are
maybe new to chess way he is the third
highest rated uh chinese player behind
the dingle dingler and
van gaal you we we've seen many of his
games he's a really really strong player
and a very very strong attacking player
at that and joe engine she has been
holding the title of women's world
champion since uh may 2018 uh and uh
well also a very very strong player but
uh she is the only woman in the field
there are 16 players here in this
tournament and she is the only woman
grandmaster uh she's the fifth uh pers
uh fifth uh woman to ever cross the 2600
barrier uh regarding classical raiding
uh and uh well it's uh it is just a very
very enjoyable game uh she's uh not the
highest rate that's currently highest
rated is ho ifan but hoiyifan has been
out of the chess world for for quite a
while now we don't know if she will ever
return and i believe alexander
goriachikana is currently higher rated
than uh
than you and jun she is i believe third
highest rated in the world now uh but
okay that being said uh let's check out
the game and enjoy some chess so wei yi
uh opens with uh c4 he goes for the
english opening uh and uh julian jung
goes for knight to f6 uh we have g3 e6
and now bishop to g2 and pawn to d5 uh
we have knight to f3 and she goes after
the grab d captures on c4 uh the
neocatalin
defense accepted we have castles and not
knight b to d7 queen to c2 now going
after the c4 pawn and she defends at
knight to b6 with a4 trying to chase
away the knight and she defends with
pawn to a5 we have knight to a3 going
after the pawn and the bishop captures
an a3 so this is all standard stuff all
been played before uh you give up the
bishop fair but you have a nice pawn on
c4 so rook captures on a3 we have
castles and now pawn to e4 and here uh
it seems that uh she prepared very well
as way ye already had this position in
2017 again it's the
uh ruslan ponomariov he won the game in
the in the dungeon
super grand master tournament in china
uh in that game e5 was played uh sorry
e5 was played by black but here she
plays bishop to d7 still not a new move
there is a game where this move was
employed but it continued with knight to
the e5 however here we have a pawn to d4
and it is now already as of movie 11
that we have a completely new game uh so
let's see how she continues uh
uh you could just continue with some
like bishop to c6 continuing development
but she goes for c captures on b4 she
captures alpassang and this is a rapid
game and of course the choice definitely
makes sense if you're a human you want
to get rid of your doubled pawn and you
want to destroy white's very strong
center so this is an automatic uh c
captures on d3 rook captures on d3 now
lining up the rook with the queen and
now she even goes for knight captures on
e4 and this is a very very risky grab
but only if white uh
pl plays this
you know to absolute perfection and here
we does not continue in the most
aggressive way possible which is very
odd uh here rook captures on d7 is a
move that you probably play in bullet
it's a very interesting that he decided
to go
uh for something else because you just
give up the rook for two knights for
example queen captures queen captures an
e4 queen captures an a4 offering a queen
trade but you can now even capture on b7
and it's definitely the best choice for
you however uh he wants to keep material
on the board he wants to complicate
things and he goes for the attack rook
to d4 attacks the knight she goes back
knight to f6 and now knight to e5
putting more pressure on the bishop
preparing rook to d1 and also preparing
to shift the rook over to the king side
to attack the black king so knight after
d5 closing up the
uh the d-file and now rook h4
threatening checkmate on h7 she defends
with f5 and now pawn to b3 just guarding
the a4 pawn and the bishop is now coming
to this diagonal we freed up the b2
square for the bishop queen to e7 she
develops the queen connects the rooks uh
and now we have rook to e1 uh aligning
the rook nicely with the queen uh and
now rook after d8 you could also play
rook eight to d8 but she wants this rook
to come to c8 so rook after d8 and the
bishop to b2 putting a lot of pressure
on black's king side with bishop to e8
and now nicely controlling the the
knight from from e8 and bishop to d4 now
uh we have rook eight the c8 and now
knight to d3 uh guarding that c5 square
but also the knight can now be
remaneuvered over to f4 and then putting
pressure on that e6 pawn so here bishop
to c6
and now queen to e2 yeah and here we
have knight to f6 which is very
interesting you can see that we is
attacking this e6 pawn
and there's no good way to defend it but
you don't really have to defend it just
to give you an example if you play
something like knight to d7 which is an
odd move to play white can never capture
this pawn here because if you capture it
for example queen captures the rook
captures and now you have this
incredible knight to f8 move you attack
the rook and once the rook moves you
attack the other rook and now after this
rook moves now you play knight d back to
e7 and what are you doing about the
bishop and the knight here you can't
move the bishop because you lose the
knight so the best thing you can do is
just to go after this knight attack it
twice
but still after the trade for example
rook captures bishop captures an e7 uh
we have a capture fest here captures
captures there's rook to d1 check and
white is just dead lost here because the
light square bishop and the rook are
completely winning here at bishop f1 you
can go bishop uh you can even go rook to
e8 now you can't move the rook anywhere
you have to trade so rook captures
bishop captures you attack this rook
let's say rook captures an f5 or you
don't have to capture doesn't really
matter the bishop will always find a way
bishop d7 now if you get to play bishop
h3 it is game over so you can defend the
h3 square but now bishop g4 and again
not uh not enough squares uh you're
winning this bishop and it's game over
so just to give you an example of why uh
the e6 pawn cannot be captured so she
goes for knight to f6 instead uh and now
now you could capture an e6 but still it
would blunder the game just to give you
an example of what happens here captures
captures and now knight to e4 you uh
block this rook's defense of the bishop
the bishop is now hanging you can't move
the bishop because the knight is hanging
and we would have to resign here but the
reason
this move was better than this move is
because of what way he plays he plays
bishop captures on c6 he doubles those
pawns b captures and now just knight to
e5 going after the c6 pawn and it's uh
now a much much better position than
then
she could have if she went for that idea
but okay queen to e8 defending the pawn
here and bishop back to c3 getting the
bishop out of harm's way we have rook to
d5 and now pawn to f3 it's a rapid game
so of course we cannot
they cannot explore all the options but
we can as we are analyzing it you know
from the comfort of our home uh rook c
to d8 doubling on the d file and now
pawn to g4 he continues attacking with
his rook kind of stranded here on this
h4 square with h6 she stops g5
but now just queen to c2 putting more
pressure on that f5 pawn
but now queen to e7 now she's
threatening all sorts of nasty
discoveries once the knight moves but
also this queen the c5 check could have
a very strong repercussions so g
captures on f5 uh she goes queen to c5
with check king to h1 and now e captures
on f5 uh asking what do you play here uh
he goes for queen captures on f5 and now
we have rook to e8 uh now the reason is
uh of course you are probably wondering
why not just capture the bishop uh
because if you capture the bishop it's a
it's a force to draw queen to e6 with
check and you cannot avoid the draw
queen f5 check and now if you repeat we
just go queen to e6 with check and if
you go king daytrade you can even win
with rook captures on h6 check captures
now the nightfalls and now you just get
checkmated queen f7 checking your trade
knight to g6 will be checkmate so after
queen captures on f5 she goes rook to e8
now uh there is no more queen to e6
check and now the bishop is just hanging
also the knight is hanging so is there
anything way you can do here to save the
game well that is exactly what we are
going to do here in the pause the video
moment feel free to pause the video
while i give you a couple of uh seconds
and try to find the only move that saves
the game for wii u while i give you a
couple of seconds
i said that twice i know
[Music]
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting this
uh incredible move and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show it is a
rook to g4 that's how you save the game
uh and the the reason for that is if of
course the the rook is captured then you
now again have access to this f7 square
queen to f7 check king to h7 if you go
king to h7 you're even gonna lose the
game uh and if you go king to h8 it's
even worse if you go king to h8 we just
deliver one check and now uh we've
opened up this diagonal so it doesn't
matter this will just be checkmate so
you can't um go here and allow a check
you have to play king to h7
but even here just queen to g6 check
king to g8 and now queen captures an e8
check that will be uh game over so uh
you you can't really you can't really do
something like this uh so after rook to
g4 it would be uh well uh and not the
greatest of ideas to capture this the
only way to survive this now with black
is to go rook e captures on e5 and after
bishop captures an e5 now you're gonna
play knight captures on g4 queen to e6
with check and okay now it's a
repetition king h7 f captures on g4 and
there is no
way for black to win anything uh it's an
it's a draw they're still you know moves
to play but um
not not all that much for example if you
if you want to bring the knight into the
game you can even give up the bishop
bishop captures on g7 king captures and
now rook to f1 and you will have
sufficient pressure to to force a
perpetual here with moves like a queen
to f6 if the knight moves or
well there are many ideas you have to be
very careful not to get checkmated here
so that's the only move to actually save
the game uh for wei however after rook
to e8 he played rook to g1 which seems
like a much better idea because the g
pawn is now pinned you can play queen
captures on f6 you can play real
captures on h6 but he missed one very
important thing is that it just doesn't
work and she spots it she plays rook d
captures an e5 grabs that knight bishop
captures an e5 rook captures an e5 and
now unfortunately you can't play queen
captures an f6 yes the g pawn is pinned
but it's pinned by the rook so we can
simply eliminate the queen characters
and g1 just wins the game if king
captures now we pick up the queen we're
up a full knight of course it's a
completely winning end game so uh
there's no good move for we he moves the
queen back we have rook to d5 queen to
e2 and now rook to e5 not allowing the
queen to go to e6 queen to d2
and now just queen e3 offering a queen
trade uh you kind of have to accept this
because otherwise queen captures on f3
will come so queen captures rook
captures and now we have this end game
where she has two knights against a rook
and it is of course completely winning
but you still have to play it properly
b4 was played we have eight captures on
b4 and now a5 where he starts advancing
his past a pawn this is the only chance
he has um uh of of saving the game uh we
have knight b back to d5 and now rook to
a1 of course putting the rook behind the
pass pawn pawn to c5 now her pawns are
also marching forward rook to c4 going
after the pawn and not knight to d7
defending we have rooked the e4 offering
a rook trade but even if uh even if a
rook trade occurs here she still has a
winning position but she says no need to
do that rook captures an f3 rook the e6
and now pawn to b3 she also has pass
pawn so she will start pushing them
forward pawn to a6 we have rook to f8
now you have to guard the queening
square and rook to c6 going after the c
pawns uh we have knight to c3 now
guarding the queening square and the
rook captures on c7 pawn to b2 attacks
the rook we have rook to g1 and now just
a b1 queen so you have to give up the
rook rook captures knight captures and
the rook captures on d7
but now of course rook to a8 we have
pawn to a7 and now knight the a3 we have
broke the b7 stopping knights to b5 you
have to keep this pawn if you want to
keep your chances alive uh king to h7 we
have king to g2 and here c4 and he was
in this position on mu 51 that we
resigned the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
because it it's actually quite simple
once the king starts approaching the
past pawn pawn to c3 king e2 c2 and king
to d2 stopping promotion uh the pawn is
protected so it's merely a matter of of
one check or or rather a couple of
checks rook to d1 checking b2 and now we
bring the queen into the game and the
white king gets checkmated very soon a
queen a1 checking b3 rook to b1 with
checking to a4 and let's say knight the
c4 will be a nice checkmate so of course
he knows this after c4 he resigns the
game and another brilliant win for joe
engine in second day of this uh
wonderful ftx road to miami
preliminaries tournament so she had a
she had a pretty bad day she lost the
first three games and then uh got one
win against teemo rajab but in the
second day
as you can see uh here are all of the
games that she played so she started
with three losses but then out of the
next five games she defeated
uh four incredibly strong grand masters
including two of the candidates from the
candidates tournament so in a row she
defeated temur rajavo in the rehard
rapport then lost the radoslav
and then she defeated sam shankland and
wei yi in the eighth game so uh
definitely an incredible achievement for
her uh and if you guys are interested in
the standings you can see that she is
currently number seven out of uh out of
the very strong 16 grand masters uh and
uh if she can remain in in the lower
half then she will qualify for the main
event but currently these are the uh the
top players uh the only uh player in in
first place samuel savion followed by
arjun nergasi uh with 16 points we have
jeffrey xiung in young shisht of duda
with 13 points mamadarov and danish
geary with 12 points we have um uh zhu
and jun rihar rapport and wei yi with 10
points lavonna runyan and hans
with seven points with five points
linear dominguez shanklin with three and
temurajaba with zero points uh but also
he withdrew for from the tournament
because uh he did not have the greatest
day one and then in day two he just
started with a loss against tanish geary
uh in a position where he should have
been playing for a win and uh it seems
that he just collapsed and decided that
it would be better if he just withdraws
from the tournament uh so yeah uh that's
the game and a little bit of extra info
about the you know everything so hope
you guys enjoyed that as well uh we'll
see how how joe engine does in in the
third day and will she be able to
qualify for the main event that would be
quite um quite a success for her i would
like to thank stephen abrams nagarjuna
ponogoti david bacon ravishing reptiles
youtube and gregory piateski for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing the coverage of this
wonderful event uh until it finishes uh
so thank you i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day and
again special congratulations to
everyone who spotted that rook to g4
move uh that was not an easy one to find
here after this rook it just worked to
g4 only that saves the game uh awesome
stuff uh see you soon